- I'm just saying, I
heard though that Daniel,
did you just, right before the pandemic,
did you just say you're
giving up on video games?
And do you think that
was maybe poor timing?
(laughs)
- No, I gave up video games a while ago
because if I do video games, I
do nothing else with my life.
I have done very little
of actual productive value
while being in quarantine.
(laughs)
But I know that if I did play video games,
it would be all that I did all the time.
And this way, I can
give myself the illusion
of being productive when I
read a book for 10 seconds
or whatever it is.
(laughs)
The thing that has really
been getting us through
this quarantine has been large Lego sets,
which take up a lot of
time, are very meditative.
- Wait, what did you put together?
What's your large Lego set?
What is that?
- Well, we made a "Jurassic Park" one
which is very big.
- What?
- And we just started a
"Stranger Things" one,
which is half built.
But it's very cool, 'cause
it's got two levels to it.
It's the normal world and
then the upside-down world
that's built upside down on top.
It's very cool, we don't know how
we're gonna put it all together yet.
It could all fall apart.
- That's amazing, I feel you.
Jane, have you found any hobbies
or anything to keep you busy right now,
other than teaching your child?
- Yeah, other than struggling
through the third grade.
I have taken up ukulele
- What?
- during quarantine. (laughs)
- Are you serious?
- It's always been this thing
I wanted to be able to play,
I guess just 'cause it
seems easy to carry around.
It's a lot lighter than a harp.
(laughs)
So I've started, I've
only taken three classes
'cause as I say, I had to get in the swing
of the school thing first,
the distance learning.
And then, I got to this.
So it's been fun.
I can't play any songs
yet, just a few chords.
It's definitely my quarantine hobby.
- You're not talented enough?
That's just been rude.
That's just being greedy
with your talent.
(laughs)
That's so cool!
The ukulele is so cool.